BECOMING A TOP MODEL
IS A LOT MORE
THAN BEING FIERCE ON A RUNWAY
OR TAKING GLAMOROUS PICTURES.
BEING A TOP MODEL MEANS
ENTERING A WHOLE NEW WORLD.
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
IS... ADRIENNE.
YOANNA'S
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
EVA.
NAIMA.
GIVE ME ONE OF THESE!
(screaming)
I'M AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
OH, MY GOD!
THIS CYCLE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THOUSANDS OF GIRLS TRIED OUT.
I FEEL LIKE I WOULD MAKE
A REALLY GREAT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WHY I SHOULD BE AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL?
MAKE ME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL, BABY.
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
HERE I COME.
BUT ONLY THE PROMISING
MADE IT TO THE SEMI-FINALS
IN LOS ANGELES.
THOSE 36 WERE INTERVIEWED.
HI!
I WANT THIS MORE
THAN I'VE EVER WANTED ANYTHING
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
SOME PEOPLE WANNA BE
BRAIN SURGEONS,
I WAS BORN TO BE A MODEL.
THAT IS MY LIFE.
DON'T GET IT
TWISTED.
THEY WERE RUNWAY-TESTED.
♪♪♪
AND SOME WERE CRUSHED.
(crying)
I'M NOT SOMEBODY THAT WEARS
MY HEART ON MY SLEEVE,
AND I'M NOT DOING IT ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
I TRIED IT.
BUT WE COULD ONLY CHOOSE 13
TO REMAIN IN LOS ANGELES
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
(screaming)
YOU GUYS ARE WELCOME,
Y'ALL.
NOW ONLY SIX GIRLS REMAIN--
KIM, LISA, NICOLE, BRE,
JAYLA, AND NIK.
TONIGHT,
AN EPISODE YOU CAN'T MISS.
(screaming)
TAKE A LOOK BACK FROM SARAH'S
CATWALK CATASTROPHE...
WHOO!
...TO CASSANDRA'S
REALLY BAD HAIR DAY.
- YOU READY?
- NO.
THREE, TWO, ONE...
PLUS, NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN
MODEL MOMENTS,
INCLUDING
A FEUD BETWEEN JAYLA AND KIM...
IT IS ON.
...MORE ADVICE TO THE GIRLS
FROM JANICE DICKINSON...
GO IN BACK OF
THE CAMERA BEFORE YOU GO ON
AND JUST GO LIKE THIS...
(sputtering)
...AND LISA'S
UNIQUE WORKOUT REGIMEN.
♪♪♪
JUST TWO MONTHS AGO,
OUR 13 FINALISTS FLEW
INTO LOS ANGELES.
YOU GIRLS ARE IT,
THE 13 THAT ARE HERE!
AND WHO WAS THERE TO LEAD THEM
INTO THE HOUSE
BUT MR. "LIFESTYLES OF THE RICH
AND FAMOUS," ROBIN LEACH.
SOMEBODY TAKE THE KEY!
OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
THIS HOUSE IS SO CRAZY.
THE ROOMS, THEY ALL HAVE
A DIFFERENT THEME.
LIKE OURS IS "BLING IT ON."
(screaming)
OUR ROOM IS PERFECT,
WHICH WAS AWESOME.
NICOLE, THIS IS US RIGHT HERE!
WHO KNEW I WAS GONNA ACTUALLY
HAVE TO SLEEP IN A BOUTIQUE?
I WENT FROM WORKING
IN ONE TO SLEEPING IN ONE.
ME AND DIANE--
I'M SO GLAD SHE'S MY ROOMMATE.
LOOK AT THESE WATCHES.
WE'RE QUIET, WE RELAX TOGETHER,
WE TALK TOGETHER.
IT'S JUST FUN,
AND I TRUST HER.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S SHADY.
BEING OPENLY GAY,
KIM STOOD OUT AMONG THE GIRLS.
ARE YOU FULL-ON LESBIAN?
I MEAN,
YOU'RE NOT BI OR...?
I ONLY DATE GIRLS, YEAH.
I THINK MY SEXUALITY ADDS
A LITTLE BIT OF POSITIVE TENSION
IN THIS HOUSE.
THEY'RE THINKING, "OH, COULD
KIM BE ATTRACTED TO ME?"
I'LL MAKE OUT WITH YOU, KIM.
I'M ALL LIKE,
WHATEVER.
CASSANDRA STOOD OUT
FOR HER LACK OF EMOTION.
HI, WHAT'S UP?
OH, EW!
CASSANDRA FLICKS
HER TOOTHBRUSH AT ME,
AND THE WATER GETS ALL OVER
MY HAIR AND EVERYTHING.
I WAS JUST KINDA LIKE,
YOU KNOW, WHY WOULD SHE DO THAT?
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE YOU WANNA
PICK ON YOU
JUST 'CAUSE
YOU'RE TOO LIKE CUTE.
LIKE YOU WOULDN'T PICK
ON LIKE--
- I'M TOO CUTE?
- YEAH.
YOU SEEM REALLY PRETTY
LIKE A FLOWER OR SOMETHING.
YOU JUST WANNA STEP ON IT.
YOU JUST WANNA STEP ON ME
AND TEAR ME APART?
- YOU'RE JUST A PAGEANT GIRL--
- LIKE WHAT'S THE DEAL?
YOU KNOW HOW
SOCIOPATHS DON'T FEEL EMOTION
AND THAT'S WHY THEY CAN
KILL PEOPLE
WITHOUT EVER LIKE
FEELING BAD ABOUT IT?
ONLY I NEVER KILLED ANYBODY.
(crickets chirping)
AND ASHLEY TRIED TO
STAND OUT
BY FLAUNTING
HER FASHION KNOWLEDGE.
MY MOM OWNS A SALON.
MY FAMILY'S
IN THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY.
I BOUGHT FOR A BOUTIQUE,
I DID THE FASHION,
I HELPED WITH THE HAIR.
I THINK THEY'LL LEAVE KIM
THE WAY SHE IS,
UNLESS THEY DIE HER HAIR DARKER.
I THINK HER EYES WOULD BE
PHENOMENAL WITH FIRE-RED HAIR.
AND I THINK THEY'LL GIVE
NICOLE A RELAXER.
I THINK
THEY'RE TAKING YOU DARKER.
OH, YEAH, NO, I'M GOING DARK.
SEE, I GREW UP
IN A SALON.
I HAVE TO CHANGE
MY HAIR EVERY SINGLE MONTH--
CUT IT OFF, PUT EXTENSIONS
IN IT, MAKE IT LONGER.
ASHLEY'S JUST FAKE,
AND I CAN'T STAND IT.
AND EVERYONE SEES THROUGH HER.
DYE IT, HIGHLIGHTS, BANGS,
NO BANGS, MORE LAYERS--
IT'S A LOT OF FUN.
AFTER GETTING
TO KNOW EACH OTHER,
THE GIRLS HAD TO WORK IT
AT A GLAMOROUS
HOLLYWOOD FASHION SHOW.
BACKSTAGE JAYLA RATTLED KIM
WITH AN INSENSITIVE COMMENT.
I WALKED UP TO KIM, AND I POKED
HER IN THE STOMACH.
I WAS LIKE, "YOU NEED
TO SUCK IN YOUR STOMACH."
SHE'S LIKE, "WHAT, ARE YOU
CALLING ME FAT?"
AND I GAVE HER THIS LOOK,
I WAS LIKE, "ARE YOU CRAZY?"
WAIT, SHE ACTUALLY SAID
YOU'RE FAT?
SHE GOES,
"GIRL, SUCK YOUR TUMMY IN."
AND I GO, "ARE YOU CALLING
ME FAT?
THAT'S SO BITCHY."
AND SHE GOES,
"YOU ARE NOT FAT AT ALL."
IT IS ON.
IF WOULDN'T GET ELIMINATED
FOR KILLING SOMEBODY,
I MIGHT JUST TAKE THAT STEP.
SO I GUESS I'D JUST LIKE HAD IT
UP TO HERE WITH JAYLA.
SHE HAS TO SAY EVERY
SINGLE THING THAT'S ON HER MIND.
LIKE CENTER YOURSELF
FOR FIVE SECONDS.
UGH, GOD,
I HATE IT.
COVERED UP OR REVEALING,
A MAMA LIKE THIS CAN STILL
BE SCANDALOUS.
♪♪♪
I WAS FIERCE ON THAT RUNWAY.
WHEN IT WAS SARAH'S TURN
ON THE RUNWAY, SHE STUMBLED.
WHOO!
THEN I DID
THE SAME THING AGAIN.
I WANNA THANK YOU GUYS FOR
COMING OUT.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
BUT HER DOWNFALL AT
THE RUNWAY SHOW
DIDN'T STOP HER
FROM PARTYING IN THE LIMO.
KIM, YOU THINK I'M BEAUTIFUL?
YEAH!
(screaming)
ALL OF A SUDDEN,
SARAH IS JUMPIN' OVER THE SEAT
AND STARTS MAKING OUT
WITH KIM!
OH, MY GOD!
AND SHE'S GOT SOME CRAZY
CANTALOUPE LIPS!
WHOO!
QUIET, QUIET!
SECOND BASE IS READY.
(laughter)
BACK AT THE HOUSE, THE MODELS
MET AN UNINVITED GUEST.
I THINK HE'S BLIND,
'CAUSE ALL HE DOES IS
RUN INTO STUFF.
ALL BIRDS ARE BLIND, THOUGH.
ARE YOU SURE?
THAT'S WHY LIKE A LOT OF BIRDS
ALMOST RUN INTO YOUR CAR--
LIKE RUN INTO YOUR HOUSE
AND ALMOST RUN
INTO YOUR CAR AND STUFF.
YEAH, 'CAUSE THEY CAN'T SEE
SO THEY LIKE--
BUT THEY CAN
SENSE WHERE THEY ARE,
LIKE WITH THEIR HEARING
AND STUFF,
LIKE THEY CAN SENSE
HOW CLOSE THEY ARE TO THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD.
I KNOW
MY BIRD CAN SEE.
MAYBE IT'S JUST LIKE THE BIRDS
OUTSIDE AND STUFF.
MAYBE.
I DON'T KNOW.
FOR THEIR PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS HAD TO FLY
AS SUPERMODEL SUPERHEROES.
♪♪♪
THAT LOOKS A LOT MORE SUPERHERO.
PICK THE INTENSITY UP!
I WISH
THAT I LIKED HER.
THERE'S SOME PEOPLE THAT GET
ON MY NERVES.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
KEEP IT STRONG!
SHE IRKS YOU
IN THE WRONG WAY.
OH, YAH, YAH!
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT POSE.
(sputtering)
♪♪♪
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY GIRLS
THAT WILL DO
ANY BETTER THAN ME.
YOU LOOK LIKE MY "MATRIX"
FANTASY RIGHT NOW!
GORGEOUS!
DIANE-- HER HAIR, HER MAKEUP,
AND HER COSTUME--
IT LOOKED LIKE
THEY WERE INTENTIONALLY TRYING
TO MAKE HER LOOK LIKE
A CHICKEN.
I WAS LIKE,
"YOU LOOK LIKE A CHICKEN,
AT LEAST YOU HAVE A THEME."
JAYLA SAYS THINGS THAT AREN'T--
THEY'RE NOT FUNNY.
WHAT'S THE OPPOSITE
OF A SUPERHERO? A CHICKEN.
THAT'S SO MEAN.
♪♪♪
YOU HAVE NO NECK AT ALL.
NECK, NECK, NECK, NECK,
NECK, NECK!
STILL LOSING YOUR NECK.
OKAY, LET'S GO.
IF WE'RE LUCKY,
WE GOT ONE SHOT OF ASHLEY.
AFTER THE SHOOT, BAD FEELINGS
BOILED OVER.
JAYLA'S JUST KIND OF MEAN
FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN OF HER.
I THINK THAT JAYLA JUST
REALLY DOESN'T HAVE
SOCIAL GRACE AT ALL.
FIVE SECONDS BEFORE
I GO ON, FOR HER TO BE LIKE--
FOR HER TO MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT MY WEIGHT.
FINE, SHE CAN BRING
SOME WEAKNESS OUT OF ME.
LIKE THAT'S NO PROBLEM, BUT
DON'T DO IT RIGHT BEFORE.
I'VE SEEN JAYLA
SAY THIS KIND OF THING,
JUST TO PEOPLE DAY AFTER DAY
AFTER DAY.
I KNOW THAT
I SAY THINGS TO PEOPLE,
AND I GET AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE
I KNOW HOW TO DO IT.
THEY KNOW I DON'T MEAN IT, AND
THEY KNOW THAT IT'S HARMLESS.
I THINK THAT'S
'CAUSE SHE'S BEEN HOME-SCHOOLED.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO INTERACT
SOCIALLY, WHICH IS SAD,
BUT LIKE I ALSO JUST--
GIRL, WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT YOU.
JAYLA, I WAS JUST
TELLING THEM THAT YOU SAY THINGS
FASTER THAN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
AND LIKE
YOU HURT PEOPLE'S FEELINGS
BEFORE YOU EVEN REALIZE
THAT YOU DO.
JAYLA'S LEARNING
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL.
LIKE SHE WAS HOME-SCHOOLED.
SHE DOESN'T REALIZE
THAT SHE OFFENDS PEOPLE.
NOTHING I SAY SHOULD BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT BUTTON YOU'RE PUSHING.
PEOPLE CAN ONLY GET USED TO IT,
BECAUSE I CAN'T CONSCIOUSLY
CHANGE THE WAY I TALK
AND THE WAY I TALK TO PEOPLE.
I'M GONNA SAY STUPID ...
ALL THE TIME,
AND PEOPLE JUST NEED
TO GET USED TO THAT.
THEN IT WAS TIME FOR THEIR
FIRST ELIMINATION.
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
ASHLEY.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE PRETTY BORING
WITH THE WALK.
ALL RIGHT, ASHLEY, SO
YOU HAD TO POSE AS A SUPERHERO,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
LESS SUPERHERO,
MORE SQUASHED VILLAIN.
YOU LOOK IN PAIN OR LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE DYING OR SOMETHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS SARAH.
HI.
SO YOU HAD TO WORK IT
AT THE "LIFE & STYLE" EVENT.
OH!
SARAH, I THINK YOU'VE GOTTA HAVE
A BETTER RECOVERY.
THINGS HAPPEN,
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE THAT, IT'S KIND OF SEXY
AND SCARY AT THE SAME TIME.
WHEN ASHLEY FAILED
TO MAKE A GOOD IMPRESSION...
SARAH...
...SHE WAS SENT HOME.
MAYBE IT'S A SHAME FOR THEM,
YOU KNOW?
MAYBE IT'S A GOOD THING FOR ME.
MAYBE THEY JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY GAVE UP YET.
COMING UP, THE GIRLS
ACT OUT THEIR OPINION OF JAYLA.
ALL'S I WANTED TO BE MY ENTIRE
LIFE WAS A STRIPPER!
BUT JAYLA DOESN'T
LET IT GET HER DOWN.
- OH, BABY!
- OH, MY GOD!
DESPITE THE STRESS
OF THE COMPETITION,
CORYN SHOWED HER PLAYFUL SIDE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I BROUGHT?
IT'S A FART MACHINE.
I WAS GONNA--
I WANNA GET SOMEBODY WITH IT.
(flatulence effect)
SORRY,
IT'S THE CHICKEN.
(flatulence effect)
IT'S MY STOMACH,
I CAN'T HELP IT.
CORYN HAS A PROBLEM,
YOU GUYS,
AND OUR ROOM
IS GONNA SMELL SO BAD!
OH, MY GOD,
THAT SOUNDS SO FAKE!
THAT'S LIKE SO HOT.
(flatulence effect)
EXCUSE ME.
SORRY.
YOU HAVE TO ROOM
WITH HER, DUDE.
WHAT IS IT?
DUDE, YOU KNOW
HOW HER STOMACH WAS HURTING?
THAT BRINGS A NEW SIDE
TO CORYN TO ME.
I DIDN'T THINK CORYN WAS LIKE
A LITTLE SCANDALOUS LIKE THAT,
BUT SHE IS, SO THAT'S COOL.
(flatulence effect)
(laughter)
PART OF BEING A TOP MODEL IS
EMBRACING NEW LOOKS.
SO I SENT THE GIRLS OUT,
NOT JUST FOR MAKEOVERS,
BUT FOR NEW PERSONAL STYLES.
WE HAVE AN IDEA FOR EVERYBODY.
MOST GIRLS WERE THRILLED.
CORYN, YOU'RE GONNA ACTUALLY
BE A BLONDE.
EBONY,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BRAIDS--
LITTLE, TINY MICRO-BRAIDS
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO HERE.
(screaming)
BUT CASSANDRA FELT DIFFERENTLY.
I HAVE A GREAT,
NATURAL BEAUTY,
AND I DON'T THINK I NEED
TO CHANGE MUCH TO ENHANCE THAT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY BYE-BYE
TO BEAUTY QUEEN,
AND YOU MIGHT WANNA GIVE
THIS TYPE OF WAVE.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE
YOUR HAIR THIS SHORT.
OH, MY GOD.
YOUR FACE IS STRONG ENOUGH
TO HANDLE THAT.
ALL RIGHT,
ARE YOU GUYS READY?
(all)
YEAH!
♪♪♪
I'VE ALWAYS HAD MY HAIR.
IF YOU GOT YOUR HAIR THAT--
ALL YOUR WHOLE LIFE,
THEN IT NEEDS TO GO.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE CASSANDRA
SHOW SOME EMOTION.
SHE'S BASICALLY BEEN
A ROBOT THIS ENTIRE TIME.
I LOVE MY HAIRCUT SO MUCH.
I NEVER WOULD'VE THOUGHT
BLONDE AT ALL.
BUT, OVERALL,
I LIKE MY MAKEOVER.
- YOU READY?
- NO.
COME ON.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
(crying)
IT'S OKAY, YOU'RE READY.
YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE
THAT SOPHISTICATED YOUNG MODEL,
LIKE FASHIONABLY CASUAL.
I LOVE
THE FINISHED PRODUCT.
IT'S AMAZING.
I FINALLY HAVE THICK HAIR.
WHEN I'M GETTING MY HAIR DONE,
I LOOK OVER AND I SEE KIM,
AND I WENT TO SAY
TWO THINGS AT ONCE,
AND IT CAME OUT, "THAT DOESN'T
LOOK THAT BAD."
SO I'M LIKE,
"JAYLA, YOU SHOULD SHUT UP."
THERE'S NO REASON TO PUT SOMEONE
DOWN RIGHT NOW.
IT'S AN OBNOXIOUS THING TO DO.
FORGET A MAKEOVER,
GET SOME PLASTIC SURGERY.
I DEFINITELY THINK THE GIRLS
ARE GETTING A WRONG SENSE
OF LIKE MY SENSE
OF HUMOR AND HOW I ACT.
IF THEY WANT ME TO BE SOMEBODY
THAT I'M NOT,
THEN WHY DO I WANNA DO THIS?
I WANT YOU TO WORK WITH
YOUR NEW LOOK.
YOU'RE A LOT CLEANER,
A LOT MORE KIND OF MOD,
A LITTLE MORE EDGY.
OBVIOUSLY, I'M STILL GONNA
BE A FEMININE PERSON,
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW I AM.
CASSANDRA'S COMPLAINING RUBBED
SOME GIRLS THE WRONG WAY.
CASSANDRA IS
CRYING ALL DAY LONG.
AND IT'S KIND OF LIKE YOU'VE
JUST GOTTA GET OVER IT.
WE HAD OUR MAKEOVERS YESTERDAY.
- YEAH?
- YEAH.
HOW DO YOU LOOK?
YOU'RE GONNA HATE IT.
- WHY?
- 'CAUSE I HATE IT.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYONE COMPLAIN
SO MUCH IN MY LIFE.
IT'S LIKE A JOKE.
WE'RE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
THE PHONE'S WORKING."
SHE'S LIKE,
"WELL, GOOD, I HAVE TO USE IT...
BECAUSE I HAVE TO TELL PEOPLE
ABOUT THIS."
I MADE A BIG DEAL
ABOUT IT, SO I'VE JUST--
I'VE GOT TO KICK SOME SERIOUS
BUTT AT THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
OTHERWISE, THEY'RE GONNA BE
LIKE, "YOU SUCK, GO HOME."
ON THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS BROKE INTO PAIRS
TO SEE WHO COULD BEST WORK WITH
THE SAME OUTFIT.
HERE WE GO.
I WANT YOU TO BRING ME
A LITTLE INTENSITY TO YOUR EYES.
- SO IF YOU'RE-- EXACTLY!
- NICE.
♪♪♪
GIVE US SOME LIFE,
LIKE GIVE US SOME DRAMA.
WHERE'S THAT ENERGY YOU HAD
THIS MORNING?
I'M JUST GETTING DEAD
CARCASS ON A FENCE RIGHT NOW.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
I'M TRYING
A LITTLE BIT TOO HARD.
I HOPING THAT IT DIDN'T GO THAT
BAD AND I'LL BE ELIMINATED.
BUT, IN ALL HONESTY,
IT MIGHT'VE GONE THAT BAD.
I LOVE YOUR CREATIVITY,
AND YOU'RE GIVING ME
GREAT RANGE.
THAT HORSE IS LIKE, "GET OFF
OF ME, I DON'T KNOW YOU!"
I WANNA RIDE
A HORSE SO BAD, DUDE.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
I'M GONNA RIDE
A FRIGGIN' HORSE.
I NEED TO TAKE MY CLARITIN
FIRST.
LATER THAT NIGHT,
JAYLA SHOWED OFF HER SIX-INCH
STRIPPER HEELS.
THOSE ARE THE MOST FUN SHOES IN
THE WORLD, AREN'T THEY?
THOSE ARE
HOOKER SHOES, FOR REAL.
I'M THE ONE PERSON THAT DOESN'T
HAVE ONE SET BEST FRIEND HERE.
YOU KNOW, I TRY TO BE COOL
WITH EVERYBODY.
I COULDN'T EVEN BE A STRIPPER.
I'D BE LIKE THIS, HOLD ON.
YOU WANT ME
TO GET UP ON THAT BALL,
YOU MUST BE OUT YOUR DAMN MIND.
LAP DANCE!
LOOK AT MY HAIR,
LOOK AT MY HAIR.
LOOK AT MY HOOKER BOOTS.
LOOK AT THOSE BOOTS.
LOOK AT ME WALK
IN THESE BOOTS.
YOU WANNA BE A STRIPPER?
THAT'S SO ANNOYING.
I WAS RAISED IN HIGH SOCIETY,
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE
IN THAT KINDA THING.
ALL'S I WANTED TO BE MY ENTIRE
LIFE WAS A STRIPPER.
(laughs)
TOWARDS THE END OF THE NIGHT,
I JUST WANNA GO TO BED.
I WANT EVERYONE
TO JUST LEAVE ME ALONE.
I'M SICK OF HAVING TO BUTT IN
ON EVERYBODY'S CONVERSATIONS.
NOBODY EVER COMES TO ME.
NO ONE EVER WANTS
TO TALK TO ME.
JAYLA COMES OFF
AS THE BAD, STRONG GIRL,
BUT EVERYONE'S A LITTLE
SENSITIVE INSIDE.
DO THAT AGAIN, DO THAT AGAIN!
♪♪♪
JAYLA!
IT'S ALL IN GOOD FUN.
JAYLA, BRING YOUR SHOES.
I'M TIRED, AND I'VE GOT ALL
THESE GIRLS RUNNING AROUND.
I WASN'T IN THE MOOD FOR IT.
THAT LOOKED
A BIT TOO NATURAL FOR ME.
(laughter)
GO, BABY.
(indistinct shouting)
LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN,
DO WE HAVE A PERFORMANCE
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
AND SHE'S PUTTING ON THE SHOES.
(laughter)
OH, MY GOD!
(indistinct shouting)
FINALLY, I DID SOMETHING
THAT WAS FUNNY FOR ONCE.
I'M GLAD NO ONE TOOK IT
THE WRONG WAY.
BUT IT CAN'T BE
ALL FUN AND GAMES,
AS EBONY SOON LEARNED
IN JUDGING.
WHAT CONFUSES ME, EBONY, HERE,
IS THAT YOU'VE ABSOLUTELY
GOT NO FACE
IN THIS PICTURE WHATSOEVER.
HAIR IN THE FACE I THINK IS
FOR UGLY GIRLS.
EBONY EXHIBITED ALL
THE PERSONALITY IN THE WORLD,
BUT WHEN SHE COULDN'T TRANSLATE
THAT INTO A PHOTO...
THANKS, EBONY.
...SHE WAS SENT HOME.
I WISH I KNEW
I HAD A PRETTY BAD PHOTO.
I'M SAD THAT I GOT ELIMINATED.
I'M HEARTBROKEN.
COMING UP, CASSANDRA WINS
THE TITLE OF MISS CONTROVERSY.
SO YOU'RE NOT READY TO CUT
YOUR HAIR?
NO.
YOU JUST GOTTA LEAVE
MY SET, OKAY?
THE DECISION
WAS A LITTLE BIT SILLY.
I DON'T THINK AN INCH OF HAIR
IS THAT BIG OF A DEAL.
AND LATER,
JANICE DICKINSON RETURNS.
YOU FEEL LIKE THAT YOU'RE
A TOUGH CHICK.
YOU GOTTA DO THE SHORT
HAIRCUT THING AND THE MOHAWK
AND BE LIKE MASCULINE.
HELLO?
(all)
HI!
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
WELL, GUYS, I HAVE A LITTLE
SPECIAL FRIEND WITH ME HERE.
TO ME, IN FASHION, IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE FABULOUS FIERCE,
THE FEROCIOUS PEOPLE.
MISS BEL-AIR,
COME ON OUT HERE!
HELLO, MY LITTLE DIVAS,
HOW ARE YOU?
I LEARNED HOW
TO WALK, PUT ON MAKEUP,
BE FIERCE FROM DRAG QUEENS.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE GONNA
WALK A LITTLE BIT.
THINK FIERCENESS.
- WORK IT!
- WORK, BABY, WORK!
YES, NICE!
COME ON, GIVE IT TO ME.
NICE, NICE.
YOU KNOW, LET ME FALL OUT
THE SOCKET FOR THEM.
LET ME SHOW THEM HOW TO WALK.
FALL OUT, BABY,
FALL OUT.
IT'S AMAZING TO WATCH SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN WALKING FOR SO LONG
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT EVEN TRYING.
IT'S AS THOUGH IT'S LIKE
SHE WAS MEANT TO DO THAT WALK.
BUT THAT WASN'T THE ONLY DIVA
THEY WENT TO SEE.
I LOOK UP, AND THERE'S MISS JAY
IN SOME CRAZY GETUP AS USUAL.
I KNEW RIGHT THEN I DON'T THINK
I WAS GONNA HAVE
A RELAXING AFTERNOON.
RUNWAYS HAPPEN
WITH DIFFERENT VENUES.
SO, TODAY, YOU'LL HAVE TO WALK
AROUND THE PERIMETERS
OF THE SWIMMING POOL.
♪♪♪
BRE, FOR THE ORIGINAL WALK,
I THOUGHT SHE WAS GREAT.
OKAY, SHE'S WORKING IT OUT.
KYLE JUST NEEDS TO BE
COMFORTABLE WITH BEING TALL.
THEY DO SAY SEX SELLS.
TIPPY TUMBLES, BETTER KNOWN
AS "MISS SARAH."
I HOPE I GET
TO LIKE PROVE MYSELF TO JAY
THAT I DON'T REALLY SUCK
ON THE RUNWAY
AS MUCH AS EVERYONE THINKS I DO.
SARAH, I NEED MORE NET,
MORE NET, BABY.
SARAH, CLEAN IT UP.
Y'ALL CAN'T BE THAT NASTY
OL' GIRLS.
BABY, WAIT, NAIL CHECK, NAIL
CHECK, NAIL CHECK, NAIL CHECK.
NA-- OH!
WHAT?
DO YOU BITE YOUR NAILS?
GIRL, THAT'S NOT CUTE,
THAT'S NOT CUTE.
IF I AM A PHOTOGRAPHER
AND HAD TO TAKE YOUR PICTURE,
LIKE THIS-- YOU GOT BEAT UP,
BUSTED UP, MAN FINGERS--
THAT'S NOT CUTE.
THE GIRLS GOT A NATURE LESSON
WHEN THEIR UNINVITED GUEST
RETURNED.
THAT'S FUNNY,
'CAUSE THERE WAS THIS BIRD
THAT KEEPS LIKE KNOCKING ON
OUR WINDOW.
I THINK IT'S BLIND OR SOMETHING.
WE NAMED IT
MR. BOJANGLES.
WE GONNA SIT OUTSIDE?
- KIM!
- WHAT?
OH, MY GOD!
IS THAT BO?
I THINK IT'S BO!
IT MUST BE BO.
WE DIDN'T LET IT IN THIS TIME.
MAYBE THE BIRD LIKE
LIVED INSIDE,
AND NOW THE BIRD'S ALL,
"I WANNA BE BACK--
I WANNA GO HOME!"
(screams)
BE CAREFUL, BO!
OH, NO!
(screaming)
OH, HE FLEW DOWNSTAIRS.
NO!
(screaming)
HE WANTS TO BE ONE OF THE GIRLS.
HE WANTS TO BE A TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
CASSANDRA CONTINUED
TO WORRY ABOUT SPLITTING HAIRS.
TYRA SAID LAST NIGHT AT
THE ELIMINATION
THAT SHE WANTED TO CUT MY HAIR
EVEN MORE.
THIS IS NOT THE HAIRSTYLE
THAT I TOLD HIM TO GIVE YOU.
SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU
GET THE HAIRCUT
THAT I WANTED YOU TO HAVE.
THE QUESTION IS, DO YOU LOVE
YOUR HAIR MORE
THAN YOU LOVE THIS OPPORTUNITY?
HAVEN'T DECIDED YET.
AND AT SUE WONG'S
RUNWAY CHALLENGE,
THE GIRLS HAD TO STRUT THEIR
STUFF ON A ROTATING PLATFORM.
YOU'RE AN EXOTIC
MONGOLIAN PRINCESS.
WHOOPS.
A LITTLE TIPSY.
SO I'M TRYING TO KEEP
MY BALANCE,
AND I COULDN'T STOP LAUGHING.
A LITTLE ROUGH LANDING.
MORE ELEGANCE,
MORE GRACEFULNESS.
KIM LACKS CONFIDENCE.
♪♪♪
I'M LOVIN' IT.
I'M FEELIN' THE ATMOSPHERE.
I'M BEAUTIFUL,
AND I HAVE THIS GRACE.
AND I'M JUST FEELING
SO CONFIDENT
AND SO GOOD ABOUT MYSELF.
I'M IN THIS HUGE WEDDING GOWN
KINDA THING.
STAY CENTER, STAY CENTER.
KEEP YOUR TRAIN
BEHIND YOU.
SARAH WAS RATHER AWKWARD.
♪♪♪
KIM AND SARAH'S RELATIONSHIP
TOOK A BIG PLUNGE.
I'M A SEXUAL PERSON.
I AM YOUNG, AND I GUESS,
UM, CURIOUS.
I TOLD KIM SHE'S SPENDING
TOO MUCH TIME WITH THAT GIRL.
IF I WAS HER GIRLFRIEND,
I'D BE LIKE,
"ALL RIGHT,
NOW EXPLAIN THAT."
I JUST DON'T REALLY WANNA HAVE
ANYTHING INTERFERE WITH
THE COMPETITION,
BUT LIKE SHE'S SUCH
A BLONDE-HAIRED GIRL, YOU KNOW?
I LOVE BLONDES, I REALLY DO.
'CAUSE WE'RE FLIRTY,
BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT.
THE ONLY THING IS, THOUGH, IS
THAT SHE'S GAY, SO IT'S WEIRD.
OH, I'D JUST SAY GOOD-BYE NOW.
I DON'T SWING THAT WAY,
AND YOU KNOW IT.
YOU MIGHT.
ALL IT WAS
WAS A STUPID PICK-UP.
WHAT IS SHE GONNA DO, FLY AND
COME SEE YOU EVERY WEEKEND?
YOU GOTTA STICK
TO REALITY, SWEETHEART.
THE NEXT MORNING, THE GIRLS
HAD TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT,
RUNNING ON A MOVING WALKWAY
WHILE STILL LOOKING FIERCE.
I WAS REALLY, REALLY
IN A BAD MOOD TODAY
'CAUSE I ONLY GOT
AN HOUR OF SLEEP LAST NIGHT.
IT REALLY WASN'T MY FAULT.
IT WAS ALL KIM'S FAULT.
YOU CAN HOLD THE PURSE
IN A DIFFERENT WAY IF YOU LIKE.
THINK PRETTY, BUT STILL SCARED,
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
A LITTLE TOO "AIY, OOH, AIY."
JAY WAS LIKE, "I WAS TOLD THAT
YOUR HAIR EXTENSIONS
JUST DON'T WORK ON YOU,
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE THEM OUT."
SHE CAN BE TOWARDS THE END
OF THE DAY.
ARE THEY COMING OUT, THOUGH?
THEY'RE JUST TAKING
A LONG TIME.
CUTE!
THAT'S A GOOD HAIRCUT.
BEAUTIFUL.
THESE ARE GOOD, JAYLA,
KEEP IT GOING!
GOOD,
RIGHT IN THERE.
EXCELLENT!
AND CASSANDRA MADE
A FATEFUL DECISION.
ROB'S READY TO CUT YOUR HAIR.
I'M NOT GONNA CUT IT, JAY.
SO YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO.
I REALLY DON'T HAVE TIME
FOR THIS TODAY,
SO YOU JUST GOTTA
LEAVE MY SET, OKAY?
♪♪♪
I HAVE TO BE MYSELF,
AND I WANNA WALK
OUT OF THIS COMPETITION
KNOWING THAT I DID WHAT I THINK
WAS RIGHT IN THE LONG RUN
AND THAT INCLUDES
NOT LETTING PEOPLE
TRY AND CHANGE THE WAY I AM.
HELLO?
TYRA?
- YEAH?
- IT'S JAY.
PAGEANTS BUILD YOU AND BUILD
YOUR CHARACTER,
WHEREAS MODELING
ALMOST STRIPS YOU DOWN
AND TURNS YOU INTO A PUPPET.
TYRA MAIL.
NO, THAT'S NOT TYRA MAIL,
THAT'S SOMETHIN' ELSE.
WOW, SHE'S GONE ALREADY?
"HEY, GIRLS.
"WELL, I CAN'T SAY YOU DIDN'T
KNOW IT WAS COMING,
"BUT I'M TOTALLY ALL RIGHT,
"AND I WISH YOU ALL
NOTHING BUT THE BEST.
"I HATE THIS.
"MODELING IS NOT FOR ME.
"EVERYTHING WE DID-- SHOOTS,
RUNWAY CHALLENGES, ET CETERA,
"ESPECIALLY THE MAKEOVER--
DUH--
"--I REALLY DIDN'T LIKE.
"REALLY, THE ONLY THING
THAT MADE IT FUN
"WAS BEING WITH YOU GUYS.
"I'M NOT WORRIED
ABOUT YOU.
LOVE, CASSANDRA."
SHE KNEW WHAT
SHE WAS GETTING INTO.
SHE KNEW THEY WERE GONNA DYE
HER HAIR,
CUT HER HAIR, DO SOMETHING.
THERE WERE SO MANY OTHER GIRLS
THAT WOULD'VE LOVED,
LOVED TO BE IN HER POSITION.
SHE WAS LIKE REALLY RANDOM
LIKE WHEN SHE SAID STUFF,
BUT LIKE SHE'LL DEFINITELY
BE MISSED, YOU KNOW.
ME, PERSONALLY, I THOUGHT THE
DECISION WAS A LITTLE BIT SILLY.
I DON'T THINK AN INCH OF HAIR IS
THAT BIG OF A DEAL.
I DON'T KNOW,
I THINK SHE WAS BEAUTIFUL,
AND I DO THINK SHE HAD
POTENTIAL.
SHE'S PROBABLY GLAD SHE
FOUND OUT NOW RATHER THAN HAVE,
YOU KNOW, TRY THE REST
OF HER LIFE
SOMETHING
AT THE END SHE WOULDN'T LIKE.
I CUT MY HAIR, AND I DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
MY HAIR WAS PROBABLY
LONGER THAN HERS, AND I CUT IT.
I PROBABLY FELT LIKE HER
BEFORE,
WHERE IT'S LIKE
THIS IS TOO MUCH.
I DON'T WANT THIS.
BUT THEN, I DON'T KNOW,
I GUESS SHE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE SAME PULL THAT I DID.
NOBODY REALLY CARED
ABOUT CASSANDRA LEAVING.
EVERYBODY HAS SELFISH
INTENTIONS.
EVERYBODY IN THIS HOUSE
DOES NOT HAVE A GOOD SPIRIT.
EVERYBODY DOES NOT GIVE OFF
GOOD VIBES AND ENERGY,
AND EVERYBODY IS
NOT AS CARING AND AS NICE
AS THEY WANT TO MAKE IT SEEM.
BUT DESPITE
ONE GIRL LEAVING,
THE MODELS STILL HAD TO FACE
ANOTHER ELIMINATION.
AND IT WAS
SARAH'S SHAKY PERFORMANCE
THAT CAUGHT THE EYE
OF THE JUDGES...
IT LOOKS REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
IN PAIN.
I THINK POISE IS
THE OPERATIVE WORD HERE.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU NEED
TO WORK ON.
...AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
KIM.
KIM TAUGHT ME A LOT
ABOUT MYSELF.
BACK TO BOONEVILLE, I GUESS.
JUST GO FOUR-WHEELIN'
AND COW-TIPPIN'
AND GROCERY STORE CHECKING.
I DO HOPE I FIND SOMETHING
I'M GOOD AT, THOUGH.
COMING UP, JANICE RETURNS.
YOU GRAB THE IMPLANT
AND YOU'RE PLACING IT.
THE OTHER HAND COULD
BE, UGH.
AND JAYLA LETS LOOSE.
YOU'RE A STUPID,
STUPID BITCH.
LISA'S CONFIDENCE GOT
ON THE OTHER GIRLS' NERVES,
AS SHE BEGAN TO GIVE
EVERYONE ADVICE.
TO DO YOUR BEST, YOU NEED
TO POSE IN FRONT OF THE MIRROR
AND DO FACES THAT AREN'T THE
FACES THAT YOU NORMALLY DO.
I WANT YOU TO GO DO THAT
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN LISA DRINKS,
SHE JUST LETS HERSELF COME OUT
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
- I WANNA TELL YOU SOMETHING.
- WHAT?
CORYN, DO YOU WANNA
PUT YOURSELF IN THE LABEL
OF BEING A SPORTS GIRL,
LIKE WORKING FOR ADIDAS?
I'M TRYING TO DO
ALL-AROUND STUFF.
EXACTLY.
CORYN-- ALL SHE TALKS ABOUT
IS WORKING OUT,
HOW HER LEGS JIGGLE,
BUT SHE'S LIKE SO SKINNY.
DID THEY NOT TELL YOU
THAT YOU LOOK TOO MUSCULAR
AND THAT YOU--
NO, THEY DIDN'T SAY
I LOOKED TOO MUSCULAR.
YOU'VE GOT A VERY MUSCULAR BODY.
IT'S VERY SORT OF SPORTS
KIND OF MODELING,
BUT YOU'VE GOT
TO BE ABLE TO WEAR DRESSES.
IT'D BE BEST IF YOU JUST ATE
AND YOU DIDN'T WORK OUT.
WHY WOULD I LISTEN TO
SOMEBODY I'M COMPETING AGAINST?
THAT'S KIND OF STUPID,
ISN'T IT?
THEN DON'T.
I'M NOT GOING TO.
LISA SAYS I'M TOO THIN,
AND I NEED TO STOP WORKING OUT.
I WAS WORKING OUT LAST NIGHT,
SO... (chuckles)
THAT BITCH IS SHADY.
OH, MY GOODNESS,
THAT MAKES ME LAUGH.
THAT BITCH IS SO COMPETITIVE,
SHE DOESN'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT SHE'S GOING FOR ANYMORE.
THE GIRLS MET WITH CO-OWNERS
OF SMASHBOX ENTERPRISES,
DEAN AND DAVIS FACTOR,
WHO READ THE GIRLS' CRITIQUES
OF EACH OTHER...
CORYN.
"TOO SKINNY FOR ME
AND MUSCULAR."
...WHICH LED TO LISA VERSUS
CORYN, ROUND TWO.
IT'S JUST GONNA MAKE
YOU FEEL BAD.
ACTUALLY,
IT'S MAKING ME FEEL BETTER,
IF YOU CAN JUST CUT OFF THAT
WHOLE THING.
THAT'S FINE.
WITH THE PRESSURE
OF THE COMPETITION MOUNTING,
KIM DISCOVERED A NEW TALENT.
♪♪♪
MY FRIEND JUST SENT IT TO ME
IN A PACKAGE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO WORK THIS.
(playing harmonica)
♪♪♪
BREAK IT, GIRL!
WHOO!
GET OFF MY BACK.
(English accent)
IS THAT YOUR BEST SHOT?
SHE TAKES THAT HARMONICA
SERIOUS.
♪♪♪
THE GIRLS'
PHOTOGRAPHER THAT WEEK
COMBINED EXPERIENCE WITH SASS.
JANICE DICKINSON,
EVERYBODY.
(all cheering)
THAT'S ALL I GET?
DOWN ON YOUR KNEES,
GIRLS.
BUT WHEREVER JANICE GOES,
CONTROVERSY'S SURE TO FOLLOW.
HOW FLEXIBLE
ARE YOU?
I'M PRETTY FLEXIBLE.
GOOD, GOOD, GOOD,
'CAUSE I'M GONNA INCORPORATE
THE LIMBS AND A LOT OF LEGS.
JANICE IS A LITTLE BIT
INTIMIDATING AT FIRST,
'CAUSE JANICE IS SO FORWARD,
AND SHE JUST CONFRONTS YOU
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
YOU FEEL LIKE
THAT YOU'RE A TOUGH CHICK,
YOU GOTTA DO THE SHORT HAIRCUT,
THE MOHAWK,
AND BE LIKE MASCULINE.
GO DO 20 JUMPING JACKS
RIGHT NOW.
DO 20.
GO IN BACK OF
THE CAMERA BEFORE YOU GO ON
AND JUST GO LIKE THIS...
(sputtering)
(neighing)
BLOW THE TENSIONS
OUT OF YOUR MOUTH.
THE THEME TO THAT WEEK'S
PHOTO SHOOT
WAS A TONGUE-IN-CHEEK TAKE
ON THE EXTREMES
OF PLASTIC SURGERY.
HOLD IT OUT STRAIGHT
AT ME.
LOOK AT YOURSELF IN THE MIRROR.
BRE NEEDS MORE EXPERIENCE
IN FRONT OF A CAMERA.
HER MOVEMENTS WEREN'T FLUID.
YOU GRAB THE IMPLANT
AND YOU'RE PLACING IT
LIKE A PERFUME AD,
AND THE OTHER HAND
COULD BE, UGH.
LOOK AT ME, LOOK AT ME,
LOOK AT ME, LOOK AT ME.
DON'T--- DON'T--
DON'T LOSE THE LIGHT, HONEY.
NO, NOT...
(gagging)
NOT LIKE YOU'RE DRUNK.
IT'S SO NATURAL
FOR HER TO BE LIKE THAT.
ANY REMARKS FROM THE SIDELINES
IS NOTHING BUT JEALOUS.
THIS GIRL'S A STAR.
MY COSMETIC SURGERY IS GONNA BE
A BREAST REDUCTION.
- OW.
- REALLY HURTS?
YEAH, 'CAUSE THEY'RE TAPED
DOWN WITH LIKE...
GAFFER TAPE?
IT HURT VERY BAD.
I COULDN'T EVEN BREATHE.
GIVE ME DIANA, PLEASE.
OKAY, NOW WORK THE FACE,
HONEY BUN.
I WANT FACE!
I WANT A BEAUTIFUL FACE,
GIRLFRIEND.
I'M GIVING YOU EVERYTHING I GOT.
WHEN I FIRST MET DIANE, I GOT
A HUGE SENSE OF INSECURITY.
DIANE NEEDS TO STOP
REELING HER HEAD BACKWARDS.
WELL DONE.
IT'S A TOUGH RIDE,
AND ONLY THE STRONG SURVIVE.
SO WHEN YOU GET HOME TONIGHT,
DON'T BE DOGGING ANYBODY
IN BACK OF YOUR BACKS,
BECAUSE IT ALL GETS
AROUND IN THE INDUSTRY.
IN THE END, DIANE'S CRITICAL
FLAW WAS HER DWINDLING SPIRIT.
DIANE, I FOUND THAT YOU WERE
QUITE NERVOUS.
- I MEAN, I'M BEING MYSELF.
- YOU'RE NOT BEING YOURSELF.
YOU'RE SO NERVOUS.
I ALWAYS FEEL WITH YOU THAT
YOU FEEL SLIGHTLY EMBARRASSED,
AND YOU SHOULDN'T.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
GOOD-BYE, SWEETIE.
THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS JUST-- IT'S LIKE
A BABY CRAWLING.
LIKE I'M JUST
LEARNING TO CRAWL,
BUT BELIEVE ME, I'M GONNA BECOME
AN ADULT IN THIS INDUSTRY.
SO THIS IS A BLESSING,
ACTUALLY, TO BE HERE.
♪♪♪
THEY HAD TO KICK DIANE OFF,
'CAUSE I'M TOO MUCH COMPETITION.
I'M THE NEW PLUS-SIZE MODEL.
I'M EMBRACING IT.
(girls giggling)
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET
FOR GETTING IN MY LANE.
BEING ABLE TO SELL A PRODUCT IS
VITAL FOR ANY TOP MODEL,
SO THE GIRLS HAD A CRASH
COURSE IN PRODUCT ENDORSEMENT
WITH COMEDIAN CHRIS SPENCER.
I'M NOT SCARED TO GET IN FRONT
OF SOMEBODY AND TALK.
YOU HAVE A PRODUCT YOU WANNA
TELL ME ABOUT?
I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU ABOUT "ANTM" HONEY
AND BANANA FACE CREAM.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD
A CAVITY?
NO, ANYWAYS, I WANNA TALK
TO YOU ABOUT THE PRODUCT--
DOESN'T SHE HAVE
BEAUTIFUL TEETH?
CAN I GET MY SHADES,
'CAUSE HER TEETH ARE SO SHINY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD
OF "ANTM."
- "ANTM"?
- YES.
ANTENUM?
ANTENUM HALLOWEEN MASK.
NO, YOU HAVE TO LISTEN.
YOU'RE GIVING ME TOO HARD
OF A TIME.
I'M SORRY.
NOW, HOW DID YOU KNOW
THAT THIS WOULD WORK?
I WAS EATING AND I WAS
LIKE, "WOW, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF I PUT THE HONEY AND BANANAS
ON MY FACE?"
YOU'S A GENIUS.
WE HAVE CLEANSERS AND CREAMS
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
I WANT YOU TO DANCE WHILE
YOU DO THE WHOLE INTERVIEW.
♪♪♪
(moaning)
YOU GOTTA BE ABLE TO SELL
THAT PRODUCT.
YOU CAN'T LET ME SWAY YOU AWAY.
BACKSTAGE, TENSIONS BETWEEN
LISA AND CORYN EXPLODED.
THEY WERE ALL
LAUGHING AT ME LIKE,
"I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU GOT UP
AND YOU STARTED DANCING."
AND THEN CORYN SAID...
"YOU NEED TO COME UP WITH
ANOTHER DANCE MOVE"
IS WHAT YOU SAID.
EXACTLY.
THAT WAS MY LIMIT.
YOU NEED TO STOP HATING
ON PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY ME.
WHY ARE YOU STILL TALKING TO ME?
SHUT UP!
THAT IS SO RUDE.
GROW UP, CORYN.
YOU'RE BASICALLY PRESENTING
YOURSELF LIKE A MORON, OKAY?
AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING,
ALCOHOLIC BITCH?
FRUSTRATED WITH GROWING TENSION
IN THE HOUSE,
LISA'S DRINKING ESCALATED.
I AM IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
IN THE HOUSE RIGHT NOW.
I'M PERCEIVED DIFFERENTLY.
NO ONE'S LOOKING
AT THE GOOD THINGS I'VE DONE
OR THE NICE THINGS I'VE DONE.
NO ONE'S CUTTING ME
ANY SLACK.
I LOVE COUSIN IT.
I FEEL LIKE ME AND COUSIN IT
ARE ALMOST THE SAME.
AND SOME GIRLS WORRIED
THAT SHE WAS GOING TOO FAR.
EVER SINCE-- FUNNY, LIKE HER
WINE AND STUFF--
BUT NOW IT'S LIKE
A REALLY BIG ISSUE.
DUDE, ALL THE WINE'S GONE.
DUDE, SHE COULD NOT HAVE DRANK
FIVE BOTTLES OF ALCOHOL
IN THE LAST FOUR DAYS.
THREE DAYS,
AND SHE DID.
THIS PLACE IS VERY STRESSFUL.
WHEN YOU GET STRESSED,
THE WORST THING YOU COULD DO
IS PUT A SUBSTANCE IN YOUR BODY,
BECAUSE YOU DEPEND ON IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU'RE YOUR NORMAL SELF.
WE JUST NEED TO BE THERE
FOR HER.
THE GIRLS WERE
SENT TO A HECTIC SHOOT
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THEM
TO FILM A COMMERCIAL,
TAKE A BEAUTY SHOT,
AND TAKE PART IN A SIT-DOWN
INTERVIEW WITH "ET"
ON MTV's RYAN DEVLIN.
ACTION.
WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG,
YOU DON'T HOLD ANYTHING BACK.
BUT THIS COMMERCIAL
HAD A TWIST--
EACH GIRL HAD TO CONTRIBUTE
HER OWN PERSONAL SECRET.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I TELL MYSELF I'M BEAUTIFUL.
IT'S RELATABLE.
LISA'S SHOOT WENT REALLY WELL,
WHICH EVERYONE
REALLY WASN'T EXPECTING.
THEY GOT A REALLY HOT GUY
TO INTERVIEW US.
OH, LIKE
THAT'S GONNA DISTRACT ME?
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU,
BUT LIKE I'M ITALIAN,
AND WE'RE JUST
KNOWN TO BE SWEATY PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU FEEL STRONG...
- WHEN YOU STRONG...
- THAT'S IT.
OH, GOD.
AS SOON AS I START OFF BAD,
I BEAT MYSELF UP ABOUT IT,
AND FROM THERE ON,
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE
I COULDN'T DO IT.
WHEN YOU'RE
CONFIDENT AND STRONG...
WE'RE GONNA STOP YOU.
PULL IT BACK UP.
WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION?
THE SAME SECRET?
MINE'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
SHE'S AFRAID OF THE DARK.
BUT I'M AFRAID OF THE DARK,
AND I SLEEP WITH A NIGHTLIGHT.
JAYLA MIGHT DELIVER THAT
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
WHAT'S MY SECRET?
I SLEEP WITH A NIGHTLIGHT.
IT'S OKAY,
'CAUSE KARMA'S A BITCH.
BACK AT THE HOUSE, TENSIONS
GREW OVER THE DAY'S SHOOT.
THAT WHOLE THING
WITH ME AND NIK IS,
I'M SO SICK OF HER GIVING ME
THE COLD SHOULDER.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHY THAT IS?
NO IDEA.
WHAT DID YOU GUYS HAVE
IN COMMON TODAY?
OH, OUR SECRETS?
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S SO RIDICULOUS.
WITH ALL THE TENSION
IN THE HOUSE,
LISA AND NICOLE
DECIDED TO BLOW OFF SOME STEAM
BY DRESSING UP
IN OUTRAGEOUS COSTUMES.
I'M SURPRISED IT'S TAKEN ME
SO LONG IN THIS HOUSE
FULL OF ALL THIS
FUN STUFF TO DO THIS, ACTUALLY.
(laughs)
READY?
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WAIT, YOU KNOW
WHAT WE SHOULD REALLY DO?
WE SHOULD GET CORYN OVER HERE
AND DO THIS WITH US.
YOU TWO NEED TO BECOME BUDDIES.
NO, IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
AND I'M TOTALLY COOL
WITH THAT.
CAN YOU READ IT?
ALL IT SAYS IS THAT I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT EARLIER TODAY
AND ALL I WANTED
TO SAY IS THAT I'M SORRY.
I JUST FELT REAL BAD,
LIKE IT REALLY DIDN'T HAVE
TO GO THAT FAR,
CALLING HER AN ALCOHOLIC
AND A BUNCH OF OTHER NAMES.
THAT WAS VERY NICE.
THAT'S VERY MATURE OF YOU.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO APOLOGIZE
TO PEOPLE.
IT REALLY IS.
I'M SO HARDENED.
AT THE END OF THE NIGHT,
I GOT A LETTER FROM CORYN
ON MY BED,
AND SHE APOLOGIZED.
I'LL ACCEPT THAT.
THAT'S ALL GOOD.
- IN THAT ONE?
- I LOOKED KINDA HURT.
LET ME SEE IT.
OH, THAT'S A CUTE PICTURE.
DO THAT AGAIN.
(giggling)
I CAN'T TAKE THE PICTURE.
OH, IT'S FULL.
SORRY, GUYS.
ME AND LISA ARE FRIENDS NOW.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONFLICTS
OR ANYTHING BETWEEN US.
IN THE END,
CORYN'S APPARENT SADNESS
KEPT HER FROM BEING
A VERSATILE MODEL...
CORYN, RIGHT NOW
YOU STAND BEFORE ME--
YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
YOU'RE SO RADIANT,
BUT YOU'RE SAD.
...AND SHE WAS ELIMINATED.
IT'S MY TIME TO GO.
I'M NOT GONNA QUIT MODELING.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA
GO PURSUE.
THIS AIN'T THE END FOR ME.
JAYLA WAS LEFT
BROODING OVER JUDGING.
NEEDLESS TO SAY AT THIS MOMENT,
I'M PRETTY UPSET WITH NIK.
TYRA ASKED HER,
"WHO ARE YOU MAD AT?"
AND SHE WOULDN'T SAY.
SOMETHING WENT ON,
BUT I THINK...
ELABORATE.
IT'S NOTHING.
NIK, YOU ARE A FORTRESS.
EVERYONE WAS LIKE,
"OH, THAT'S SO NICE OF YOU.
YOU KNOW, NOT CALLING ANYBODY
OUT, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH."
'CAUSE SHE DOESN'T WANNA
LOOK BAD IN FRONT OF TYRA.
WILL NIK AND CORYN PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
OH, I WAS SO HAPPY TODAY,
SO HAPPY TODAY WHEN SHE WAS DOWN
TO THE FINAL TWO.
NIK, YOU HAVE TO WORK.
OH, I THINK
I WOULD CRY TEARS OF JOY
IF SHE GOT SENT HOME
AT THIS POINT.
THAT'S NIK.
I REALLY, REALLY HOPE
YOU SEE THIS.
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
YOU'RE A STUPID,
STUPID, BITCH.
COMING UP, WATCH WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN LISA FINALLY
COMES OUT OF HER SHELL.
♪ UH, UH, UH ♪
AND LATER,
KIM COMES UNDER ATTACK AGAIN.
GET HER, GET HER,
GET HER, GET HER!
AFTER SO MANY COMPLICATED
PHOTO SHOOTS,
I DECIDED
TO DROP BY TO SHOW THE GIRLS
THAT SOMETIMES YOU DON'T NEED
ALL THE FUSS
TO GET A FIERCE PHOTO.
- FEEL WEIRD?
- KIND OF.
I'VE NEVER PUT VASELINE
ON MY FACE BEFORE.
IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU
A GLISTENED HIGH-CHEEKBONE LOOK.
THIS IS THOSE KAMIKAZE PHOTO
SHOOTS THAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU FIRST START
MODELING WITH YOUR FRIENDS.
JUST BE VERY ETHEREAL
AND NOT SO POSEY.
MORE BABY DOLL,
LIKE, "HUH, WHAT?"
OH!
(chuckles)
AND THEN TURN BACK TO HIM
LIKE, "WHAT?"
I DID A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE I WAS HOLDING LEAVES.
KINDA LIKE PEEK.
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA.
JUST LIKE,
"I'M A BABY, AND I'M A VIRGIN."
(laughs)
"BABY."
♪♪♪
NOW, HOLD BOTH PIECES OF HAIR,
LIKE LOOK, LOOK AT ME,
LIKE,
"I'M JUST SO INNOCENT."
PUT YOUR ARMS DOWN AND RELAX.
GET A LITTLE MORE "I'M INNOCENT.
I'M JUST A BABY."
LIKE TILT YOUR HEAD BACK.
SO, KYLE,
I WANT YOU TO THINK GYPSY,
LIKE, "I'M GONNA CAST
YOUR FORTUNE."
SOMETIMES A PHOTO SHOOT
IS SHORT AND SWEET AND CUTE.
THEY DON'T TAKE ALL THE HOOPLA.
AFTER THE PHOTO SHOOT,
LISA FOUND AN INVENTIVE WAY
TO BURN CALORIES.
I EXERCISE SO MUCH.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO WORK OUT
IS DRIVING ME CRAZY.
KIM AND I, WE'RE GONNA
COME UP WITH A DANCE ROUTINE.
♪ DANCIN', DANCIN'
AHH ♪
OKAY, READY?
FIRST, YOU JUST GO SIDE TO SIDE
LIKE THIS WITH YOUR HANDS.
♪♪♪
STOP, WIGGLE IT.
♪ UH, UH, UH ♪
TURN AROUND.
♪♪♪
(laughs)
OKAY.
I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
A GOOD TIME, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T WANT
EVERYONE TO JUST SIT AROUND
AND LIKE COMPLAIN ABOUT
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW.
LIKE LET'S GET UP
AND DO SOMETHING.
♪♪♪
AHH.
(cheering effect)
A '40s-ERA PINUP SHOOT
REQUIRED THE GIRLS
TO TURN UP THE SEX APPEAL.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT THAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY--
OLD PINUP GIRL
WITH THE NEW FORD FUSION CAR.
HOLD ON TIGHT.
LET ME KNOW
WHEN YOU CAN'T BREATHE.
I'M TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
BREATHE COMFORTABLY
WITHOUT PASSING OUT.
OH, THAT'S GOOD.
NOW GIVE ME THE EYES!
YEAH, THERE'S THE EYES.
THERE YOU GO!
UH-HUH.
YEAH, GIVE ME THE TEETH,
GIVE ME THE TEETH!
YES, YES!
HEY, KIM,
YOU GOTTA THINK PINUP-Y.
OOH, LET ME SEE.
UH-HUH.
THIS IS TRULY THE MOST FEMININE
I'VE SEEN YOU LOOK.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
THERE YOU GO.
IF YOU'VE GOT IT, FLAUNT IT.
KEEP PLAYING WITH IT.
IT'S WORKING.
NICE, NICE!
KEEP WORKING ON IT, KYLE.
STICK YOUR BOOTY OUT,
KYLE!
YOU HAVE TO TWIST YOUR BUTT OUT.
FEET TOGETHER,
FEET TOGETHER.
KYLE LOOKED LIKE SHE WASN'T
AS COMFORTABLE IN THIS SHOOT
AS SHE USUALLY IS.
SHE DIDN'T REALLY GET INTO
THE CHARACTER OF A PINUP GIRL.
AFTER ALL THE PRESSURE
AT THE COMPETITION,
LISA FINALLY CRACKED.
I HATE ALL OF YOU!
I HATE THIS WHOLE THING!
(indistinct shouting)
YOU GUYS, COME ON,
HELP ME!
(laughter)
NO, LEAVE HER ALONE!
AAH!
THAT WAS THE FUNNIEST THING
I'VE EVER SEEN.
HOW GIRLIE ARE WE?
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
LIKE FACE I DO WAS NATURAL.
IT'S LIKE...
IN PHOTOGRAPHS AND IN PERSON,
KYLE FAILED
TO CONVINCE THE JUDGES
SHE HAD THE EDGE
OF A TOP MODEL,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
(crying)
I KNOW I HAVE
ALL THE POTENTIAL IN THE WORLD,
AND I JUST-- I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO USE IT.
I DEFINITELY THOUGHT I WAS
GONNA GO FARTHER THAN THIS.
(crying)
NOW ONLY SIX GIRLS REMAIN--
JAYLA, THE REBEL
JEHOVAH'S WITNESS FROM ARIZONA,
NICOLE, THE BABY-FACE STUDENT
FROM NORTH DAKOTA,
NIK,
THE SILENT THREAT FROM ATLANTA,
KIM, THE TOMBOY FROM
NEW YORK CITY,
BRE,
THE STRONG-WILLED HARLEM GIRL,
AND LISA, THE LIFE OF THE PARTY
FROM LOS ANGELES.
DON'T MISS A MOMENT,
AS WE FIND OUT WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
INSPIRATION VISITS THE GIRLS
IN THE FORM OF
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
EVA, THE DIVA.
OH, MY GOD,
SHE'S SO CUTE.
YOU JUST WANNA... KISS HER.
AND HOW CRAZY WILL THINGS GET
WHEN LISA MEETS THE WILD BOYS?
♪♪♪
OW!
(men cheering)
♪♪♪